ich rufe auf den tagesordnungspunkt 3
erste beratung des von der
bundesregierung eingebrachten
gesetzentwurfs über die feststellung
eines zweiten nachtrags zum bundes
haushaltsplan für das haushaltsjahr
2021 für die aussprache ist eine dauer
von 67 minuten beschlossen
ich eröffne die aussprache und das wort
hat als erster für die bundesregierung
der bundesminister für finanzen
christian lindner
auch präsidentin meine damen und herren
die
bundesregierung bekennt sich zur
schuldenbremse unserer verfassung so
steht es im koalitionsvertrag
wir werden ab 2023 also schon mit dem
bundeshaushalt denen wir im kommenden
sommer hier im haus fanden die vorgaben
der schuldenbremse einhalten
eine andere prognose war im januar in
einem gastbeitrag im handelsblatt zu
lesen die schuldenbremse schrieb der
damalige kanzleramtsminister sei in den
kommenden jahren in den kommenden jahren
auch bei ansonsten strenger
ausgabendisziplin nicht einzuhalten
deshalb müsse das grundgesetz geändert
werden um längere zeit höhere schulden
machen zu können nun ist helge braun
auch vorsitzt auf vorschlag der cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion zum vorsitzenden des
haushaltsausschusses gewählt worden ich
freue mich lieber herr braun auch die
zusammenarbeit mit ihnen im ausschuss
und wir wollen prüfen ob ein anderer weg
als der den sie prognostiziert haben
möglich wird
meine damen und herren der koalition
sports cup umfasst zugleich auch eine
antwort auf die pandemie sie setzen wir
mit diesem nachtragshaushalt als das
verhandlungsergebnis dreier parteien um
ich danke meinem vorgänger der dies
konzeptionell vorbereitet hat wir haben
uns ambitionierte ziele gesetzt die
korona pandemie zu bewältigen und
gestärkt aus der krise herauszukommen
für unsere aufgabe die transformation
einer der größten industrienationen hin
zur klimaneutralität wir stellen uns
dieser aufgabe in einer herausfordernden
zeit ein großer teil der öffentlichen
mittel wird für die bewältigung der
wirtschaftlichen und sozialen folgen der
pandemie verwendet und das führt zu
diesem nachtragsetat
zugleich sind durch die unsicherheiten
und einschränkungen der korona krise
viele investitionen in die
modernisierung der wirtschaft
ausgefallen die pandemie bedingten
restriktionen haben auch unsere
lieferketten gestört zudem
verteuern gestiegene energiepreise
wirtschaftliche aktivität die
herbstprojektion der bundesregierung
geht daher davon aus dass die
investitionstätigkeit der
volkswirtschaft in den jahren 2020 und
21 deutlich unterhalb des in der
herbstprojektion des jahres 2009 10 für
diesen zeitraum geschätzten volumens
geblieben ist ist von grundlegender
bedeutung jetzt einen nachholprozess zu
organisieren wir dürfen durch die
pandemie nicht auch noch zeit bei der
transformation von wirtschaft und
gesellschaft polieren
also meine damen und herren wir brauchen
den mut zum aufbruch nicht nur die
menschen benötigen einen booster auch
die wirtschaftliche entwicklung gerade
jetzt sind öffentliche investitionen und
die förderung privater die die
transformationen befördern entscheidet
dabei bedienen sich die bekämpfung der
pandemie und die transformation der
wirtschaft geradezu die zahlreichen
hilfen für unternehmen selbstständige
und beschäftige überbrücken die schwere
zeit aber langfristig wirken sie nur
wenn wir damit zugleich eine
wirtschaftliche dynamik entfachen und
mehr fortschritte wagen es geht um den
weg aus der krise und wirtschaftlichen
erfolg und um viel mehr es geht um die
verantwortung für die zukünftigen
generationen
das hat auch das
bundesverfassungsgericht
unterstrichen der maßstab für den
klimaschutz heute sind die freiheits
chancen künftiger generationen
die bundesregierung orientiert sich an
dieser entscheidung und zugleich
und zugleich müssen wir die
schuldenbremse des grundgesetzes
einhalten beides ist für die
bundesregierung verbindlich wir handeln
schnell und entschlossen mit diesem
nachtragshaushalt schaffen wir eine
basis schaffen planungssicherheit und
setzten wachstumsimpulse wir bauen
gewissermaßen eine brücke aus der
pandemien eine klimafreundliche zukunft
eine zentrale rolle spielt der energie
und klimafonds den wir zu einem klima
und transformation von weiter entwickeln
das ist das für diesen nachholprozess
geeignete instrument ich habe die kritik
der cdu csu bundestagsfraktion
wahrgenommen wir nehmen die kritik der
cdu bundestags cdu csu
bundestagsfraktion auch ernst sie
entscheidet sich wohltuend von früheren
äußerungen aus ihren reihen bei uns ist
der unterschied
bei uns ist der unterschied weniger
gross wir ihnen deshalb eine klare
zusage geben
bei der nutzung der mittel werden wir
zukünftig darauf achten dass der bezug
zu den folgeschäden der pandemie also
etwa nicht erfolgter investitionen oder
preisentwicklung jederzeit bestehen
bleibt mitnichten geht es darum
allgemeine projekte der ampel koalition
oder etwas staatskonsum zu finanzieren
die mittel des fonds werden
zielgerichtet eingesetzt für
transformative investition
[Musik]
wie im koalitionsvertrag vereinbart
nutzen der mittel aus den bereits
veranschlagten aber nicht benötigten
kredit ermächtigungen
wir schlagen vor die bereits im letzten
jahr von der vorgängerregierung erfolgte
zuweisung um weitere 60 milliarden euro
zu ergänzen mehr wäre möglich mehr ist
aber nicht nötig es werden im vergleich
zum früheren vorgehen keine zusätzlichen
kredit ermächtigungen geschaffen im
gegenteil sollten sich weitere
entlastungen im haushaltsvollzug
2021 ergeben dann werden wir vorschlagen
diese zur reduzierung der tatsächliche
nettokreditaufnahme einzusetzen
nachhaltig zu wirtschaften ist uns
wichtig denn deutschland hat auch eine
rolle in europa die rückkehr zu klaren
fiskalregeln ist entscheidend und
deshalb schließen wir für uns wege aus
die änderung der verfassung umfassen das
erfordert mut zur prioritätensetzung
aber darüber verfügen wir
christian lindner der
bundesfinanzminister hier ist eine erste
lesung zu dem gesetzentwurf zum
nachtragshaushalt
und wir hören jetzt
christian haase für die cdu csu fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
eine münze hinter dem ohr hervorzaubern
einen blumenstrauß aus dem ärmel ziehen
oder einen kleinen ball in der hand
verschwinden lassen so was nennt man
taschenspielertricks im mittelalter
standen die menschen mit großen augen
vor jahrmärkten frau gauklern und
schauten sich solche kunststücke an
heute stehen wir staunen vor den
begründungen zum zweiten
nachtragshaushalt 2021 in einer
wundersamen wandlung werden corona
kredite zu klima krediten mindestens
genauso staunen müsste der kollege türen
ich darf ihnen übrigens an dieser stelle
noch einmal zur wahl als
fraktionsvorsitzender gratulieren werter
kollege beim rechtlich deutlich weniger
zweifel achten zweiten nachtragshaushalt
2020 hatten sie im juli letzten jahres
scharfe töne angeschlagen
das sind nämlich aus ihrer rede zitieren
zitat anfang der zweite
nachtragshaushalt beeinträchtigt
wesentliche verfassungsgrundsätze wie
ehrlichkeit fälligkeit wahrheit und
klarheit
zitat ende und mit blick auf die
ehemaligen finanzminister scholz und
walter borjans fragte sich der kollege
der damals warum man in der spd nur
karriere machen könne wenn man
verfassungswidrige haushalte vorlegen
sind das die fußstapfen in die sie
treten wollen herr lindner sie sind mit
der klaren aussage angetreten die
schuldenbremse zu verteidigen und auch
in die sondierungsgespräche sind sie mit
der klaren roten linie gegangen kein
aufweichen der schuldenbremse lieber
herr finanzminister wollen sie wirklich
dieses versprechen mit ihrem ersten
gesetzentwurf brechen
denn das ist doch offensichtlich dass
sie die schuldenbremse mit diesem
waghalsigen manöver ausführen zu den
corona krediten die sie im energie und
klimafonds parken kommen ja noch die
änderungen in der schuldenregel für
sondervermögen mit dem einzigen ziel den
verschuldungsspielraum in den nächsten
jahren vollkommen unabhängig von corona
zu erhöhen und ich sage ihnen ganz
deutlich ich halte diesen
nachtragshaushalt für verfassungswidrig
ich halte diesen nachtragshaushalts für
den anfang vom ende der schuldenbremse
und das wird mit ihrem namen verbunden
sein
und meine bedenken stehe ich nicht
allein da namhafte staatsrechtler der
bundesrechnungshof oder der
wissenschaftliche beirat des
stabilitätsrats haben bereits deutliche
kritik geäußert die ausschweifende
begründung im gesetzentwurf zeigt
anschaulich was für geistige
verrenkungen nötig sind um diesen
nachtragshaushalt zu rechtfertigen da
ich die rede davon dass sich zur
pandemie bewältigung die zuweisung an
den etf im jahre 2020 bewährt habe nein
meine damen und herren wenn man einmal
bei gelb über die ampel gefahren ist
heißt das nicht dass man beim nächsten
mal bei rot fahren darf
die bisherigen kreditermächtigung haben
eine feste corona konditionierung sie
jetzt nachträglich für die bekämpfung
des klimawandels auszuweiten ist nicht
nur verfassungswidrig sondern hat einen
offensichtlichen logikfehler bereits
seit langem ist doch klar dass der
klimawandel auch eine finanzielle
herausforderung ist das hat nichts aber
auch gar nichts mit der bewältigung der
korona krise zu tun die pandemie ist
eine außergewöhnliche notsituation im
sinne des artikels 115 grundgesetz
der klimawandel ist dies nicht der
klimawandel ist eine dauerhafte
herausforderung der wir uns im rahmen
der regulären haushaltsführung stellen
muss und das können wir ohne
verfassungsbruch
meine damen und herren die fdp fraktion
hat sich in der vergangenen wahlperiode
ja immer gerne als service opposition
bezeichnet darum will ich ihnen auch
helfen etwas zu tun was nicht
verfassungswidrig ist erstens eine
konsequente aufgabenkritik wir sind uns
alle einig dass der kampf gegen den
klimawandel eine der dringlichsten
aufgaben ist das muss ich dann durch
prioritätensetzung im bundeshaushalt
widerspiegeln bevor man ausgaben erhöht
sollte man nach einsparpotenzial schauen
und ich bin erstaunt dass ich ihnen das
erklären muss herr lindner bisher war
das auch ihre linie
zweitens
aktivieren sie private investitionen zum
klimaschutz statt den nächsten
generationen riesiger schuldenberge zu
hinterlassen die finanziellen
herausforderungen sind durch die
demographie bereits groß genug schrecken
sie die zukunftsmöglichkeiten der
zukünftigen generation nicht weiter ein
drittens effiziente förderprogramme sind
einfach besser als immer mehr geld
befreien sie sich von der illusion dass
die erhöhung öffentliche ausgaben irgend
eine kurzfristige wirkung entfaltet ein
blick auf den stockenden mittelabfluss
im wk f sollte für diese einsicht
genügen stattdessen arbeiten wir mit
ihnen gerne daran plan verfahren zu
straffen förderprogramme zu entschlacken
oder noch besser stärken sie kommunale
investitionen durch einer erhöhten
umsatzsteueranteil
eigentlich müsste ich mit diesen
vorschlägen einem liberalen
finanzminister aus der seele sprechen
überzeugen sie also ihre
koalitionspartner dass dies der deutlich
bessere weg ist als immer zusätzliche
neue schulden ganz zu schweigen dass sie
ihre amtszeit mit einem verfassungsbruch
begehen ziehen sie deshalb diesen
nachtragshaushalt zu rücken
sagt christian haase für die cdu csu
fraktion
der haushaltspolitische sprecher der
unions-fraktion die auch ihre
fachpolitischen sprecher jetzt bereits
neu besetzt hat und er bekommt viel
applaus aus den reihen der union es gab
ja auch im vorfeld große große kritik
bis zur ankündigung zu klagen vom
bundesverfassungsgericht und christian
haase hat die kritik noch mal
ausführlich begründet
nächster regnet ist wurde für die spd
[Applaus]
geschätzte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen vorweg wir sind
mitten in der pandemie und auch für die
haushaltspolitik gilt weiterhin wir
werden nicht beim gesundheitsschutz der
bevölkerung sparen der schutz von leib
und leben wird auch für die neue
koalition allerhöchste priorität haben
neben dem gesundheitsschutz haben wir
uns aber in den letzten anderthalb
jahren auch sehr intensiv mit den
wirtschaftlichen folgen dieser pandemie
beschäftigen müssen dafür haben wir viel
fällt nicht brücken gebaut wir haben
brücken gebaut für arbeitnehmerinnen und
arbeitnehmer insbesondere durch das
kurzarbeitergeld damit die die vorne
diesen job hatten ihn auch nach zig die
sagen wir haben brücken gebaut für
unternehmerinnen und unternehmer die vor
der krise erfolgreich waren damit sie
durch soforthilfe durch brücken hilfe
durch den wirtschafts
stabilisierungsfonds auch nach der krise
erfolgreich sein können wir haben
brücken über diese krise gebaut aber
jetzt jetzt geht es um die frage wohin
führen eigentlich diese brücken denn die
welt um uns herum ist ja nicht stehen
geblieben es ist ja nicht nur das thema
corona was politik zu beschäftigen hat
und wir leben das wir
dass wir uns mit der frage
auseinandersetzen müssen landen die
brücken in der welt so wie sie vorher
aussah oder schlagen wir diese brücken
jetzt in die zukunft erleben weltweit
das die geschwindigkeit der
wirtschaftlichen transformation
zugenommen hat viele anderen länder
setzten darauf co2 neutral zu werden
ihre produktion weg von co2 zu führen
und uns muss klar sein wenn dieser
aufschwung den wir gerade gestalten wenn
diese in die zukunft führen sollen dann
geht das nur wenn wir möglichst schnell
in diesem land die voraussetzungen
schaffen auch hier co2 neutral zu
produzieren und auch an dieser stelle
wettbewerbsfähig zu bleiben die
kolleginnen und kollegen
und natürlich das kostet eine menge geld
und auch die brücken der letzten
anderthalb jahre haben eine menge geld
gekostet aber hätten wir weggesehen
hätten wir geben sich selbst überlassen
hätten wir nicht gehandelt dann wäre das
alles viel teurer geworden und der
schaden für unser land wäre immens viel
größer geworden deshalb ist es richtig
zu handeln wie bei kolleginnen und
kollegen
und die schrägen blick auf die zukunft
kluges handeln ist sehen wir ja schon
wenn große deutsche unternehmen jetzt
entscheidungen treffen dass die stahl
zukünftig bei fremdländischen
unternehmen einkaufen weil der co2
neutral ist und wir das angebot noch
nicht zuvor halten können und gerade
deswegen ist es zwingende voraussetzung
für die nachhaltige sicherung der
arbeitsplätze und des wirtschaftlichen
wohlstandes dieses landes dass die
brücken in der zukunft ankommen dass sie
in der co2 neutralität ankommen das ist
unsere aufgabe im hier und jetzt und
genau das genau das ist der grund
weswegen wir den energie und klimafonds
zu ein klima und transformations- fonds
weiter entwickeln wollen damit kommen
wir auch der bundesfinanzminister hat es
angesprochen der im urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichts nach nämlich
dem übergang zur klimaneutralität jetzt
zügig in angriff zu nehmen und wir
kommen damit unserer verpflichtung der
verpflichtung des staates nach leben und
gesundheit vor den gefahren des
klimawandels zu schützen wir haben keine
zeit zu verlieren und wäre das regiert
wer das bestreitet der möge sich doch
auch noch mal die bilder aus dem ahrtal
angucken ja wir brauchen die wirtschaft
wie wirtschaftliche transformation
schnell um den wohlstand unseres landes
zu sichern aber wir brauchen eben auch
zum erhalt des natürlichen lebensraums
auf dieser welt liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen und darum
und darum sage ich in aller deutlichkeit
in richtung union wer davon spricht wir
wollten mit diesem transformations- vor
nur irgendwelche ampel projekte
finanzieren der ist noch immer noch
nicht im hier und jetzt und er ist noch
immer nicht in der realität dieses
landes angekommen und
und wer dann sagt er will gegen diese
rücklage zu dieser unbedingt notwendigen
wirtschaftlichen transformation dieses
landes dann auch nach karlsruhe gegen er
will dagegen klagen der macht sich aus
opportunismus zum kämpfer gegen den
wohlstand in diesem land liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
aber gehen sie sie werden scheitern zum
einen weil wir der festen überzeugung
sind man muss eine krise auch nachhaltig
verlassen und das machen wir mit diesem
klima und transformations- und weil wir
uns auch sehr intensiv mit dem urteil in
hessen des staatsgerichtshofs
auseinandergesetzt haben und uns auch
angeguckt haben welche leitplanken
werden da eigentlich gezeichnet und
schnell feststellen konnten zum einen
sind die verfassungsrechtlichen
grundlagen sehr unterschiedlich und der
hauptkritikpunkt des hessischen
staatsgerichtshof war die fehlende
parlamentarische beteiligung und die
verletzung des budgetrechts des
landtages und ich sage ihnen das würde
bei uns ins leere gelaufen wird der
deutsche bundestag wir sind
verantwortlich für die konkrete
verwendung der mittel der sondervermögen
wir beraten jedes jahr den
wirtschaftsplan des energie und
klimafonds der haushaltsausschuss setzt
sich regelmäßig in vielen sitzungen mit
konkreten fragen des energie und
klimafonds auseinander wir schaffen kein
sondervermögen mit dem eine regierungs
frei hantieren kann wir beschließen kein
sondervermögen der bundesregierung wir
beschließen ein sondervermögen über
dessen konkreten einsatz zur
nachhaltigen bekämpfung der pandemie wir
als deutscher bundestag entscheiden
werden
wir reden also nicht von einem
sondervermögen der exekutiven sondern
von einem der legislative und das ist
der unterschied zu hessen und vielleicht
das auch noch mal ein paar wenige zahlen
gepackt das hessische sondervermögen
findet sich auf einer halben seite
zusammengefasst zwei einnahme punkte 7
ausgabe punkte für zwölf milliarden euro
der energie- und klimafonds hat im
wirtschaftsplan inventur 20 22 85 seiten
wir haben unsere hausaufgaben gemacht
und wir werden sie auch weiterhin machen
und
ein sondervermögen für dringend
notwendige
transformationsprozesse im deutschen
bundestag zu nutzen ist nichts neues
genau dasselbe haben wir in der letzten
koalition auch gemacht wir haben mit dem
2 nachtragshaushalt 20 20 28 milliarden
euro ebenfalls für transformations-
aufgaben in den energie und klimafonds
überführt und wir haben das nicht nur
mit den stimmen der union gemacht
sondern auch noch voll des lobes aus der
union sorgt der damalige
stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende andreas jung in der
debatte am 2 juli von diesem rednerpult
von einer
vitaminspritze für die zukunft unseres
landes gesprochen herr kollege
der kollege brandl sprach in derselben
debatte von diesem rednerpult davon dass
es der anspruch sein müsse nicht nur
nach der krise in einem deutschland
anzukommen wieder vor sondern zitat
unser anspruch ist deutschland damit
besser zu machen sie erkennen also die
notwendigkeit zu handeln sie haben die
instrumente die wir selbst die wir
nutzen selbst mit er dach sie sprachen
von vitaminspritzen davon deutschland
besser zu machen und heute verlauten sie
ihre eigene politik ich frage wer soll
ihm das eigentlich abnehmen
und der kollege der bundesminister sind
nates angesprochen helge braun hat ja
selbst einen vorschlag zur reform der
schuldenbremse auf den weg gebracht und
die begründung dafür die herleitung ist
genauso interessant ich zitiere helge
braun handelsblatt 21 januar 20 21
sollte eine strategische entscheidung
zur wirtschaftlichen erholung getroffen
werden ist das mit erheblichen
belastungen für den bundeshaushalt
verbunden konkret die schuldenbremse ist
in den kommenden jahren auch bei
ansonsten strenger ausgabendisziplin ase
die sie gerade gefordert haben nicht
einzuhalten helge braun sagt also
ebenfalls dass es einer strategischen
entscheidung zur wirtschaftlichen
erholung bedarf und dass diese enorme
kosten mit sich bringt trotzdem wurde
sein vorschlag insbesondere von ihrer
fraktions und parteiführung vehement
zurückgewiesen credo war keine neuen
schulden keine zusätzlichen einnahmen
kein geld für transformations- aufgaben
kommt heute noch dazu und was machen sie
machen helge braun der alles das erkannt
hat zu ihrem gesicht für die
haushaltspolitik im deutschen bundestag
zum vorsitzenden des
haushaltsausschusses des deutschen
bundestages was gilt jetzt eigentlich
bei ihnen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
und nochmal abschließen was ist der
preis des nichtstuns die brücken nicht
in die zukunft zu schlagen würde den
wirtschaftlichen aufschwung unseres
landes massiv gefährden und als stärkste
volkswirtschaft in europa würde ist die
ökonomische erholung des gesamten
kontinents gefährden heute nicht zu
handeln würde den preis in der zukunft
um ein vielfaches erhöhen weil unsere
wirtschaft abgehängt ist und bei
katastrophen wie dem aartal milliarden
an schäden mit sich bringt dieser krise
ist nicht beendet sie stellt uns vor
neue herausforderungen wir sind bereit
diese herausforderungen anzugehen der
nachtragshaushalt ist der erste richtige
schritt in die richtige richtung vielen
dank wer sagt denn es wurde für die spd
fraktion sitzt er im haushaltsausschuss
jahren diese energie und klimafonds in
gehen die 60 milliarden verschoben
werden sollen ist ein sondervermögen des
bundes wurde 2011 bereits eingerichtet
und über den bundeshaushalt hinaus
investitionen in klimaschutz und so
weiter zu ermöglichen
der soll jetzt in zukunft klima und
transformation sfo
heißen
präsidentin verehrte kolleginnen und
kollegen wir waren ja schon unter der
gruppe einiges an zumutungen gewöhnt
aber es ist schon eine bemerkenswerte
leistung eines fdp finanzministers in
seiner allerersten amtswoche gleich zwei
zentrale fdp wahlkampf versprechen zu
brechen zunächst mit dem impfzwang für
pfleger den erhalt eines elementaren
grund und freiheitsrechte der menschen
und heute das versprechen einer seriösen
haushaltspolitik
diesen ausverkauf des liberalen
tafelsilbers sollten sie dringend ihren
betrogenen wählern erklären herr lindner
der nachtragshaushalt 20 21 über 60
milliarden euro soll rückwirkend im
januar des folgejahres beschlossen
werden was schlicht absurd ist man nimmt
kein geld für ein jahr auf in dem der
bund ohnehin bereits 180 milliarden euro
schulden gemacht hat nur weil die alte
groko sich noch weitere 60 milliarden
hat genehmigen lassen und 2021 einfach
nicht mehr ausgeben konnte so wie es die
ampel nun eben auch nicht mehr tun kann
das sind doch unseriöse tricks die einer
bundesregierung unnötig sind und wenn
ich eben höhere kollege spricht dass das
geld nicht mehr ausgegeben wird dann ist
es erst recht ein argument ist heute
nicht aufzunehmen wenn sie es 2021 an
kameralistischen haushalt nicht mehr
ausgeben können dürfen sie es nicht
ausgeben das sind buchungstricks ich
kommt dazu und ja weiß es ja
offensichtlich bereits wie viel geld man
in diesen vier jahren auf pump benötigen
wird und dann fängt man lieber gleich in
den ersten tagen an richtig auf zu
schulden zudem stellen sie sich komplexe
rechtliche fragen zur für union und fdp
offenbar zu komplexe das zeigt sich am
irakischen verhalten dieser fraktion
seit 2020 werden dass er eben schon
zurecht gehört die fdp hatte noch in der
opposition ihr jetziges vorgehen in der
regierung als verfassungsfeindlich und
verfassungswidrig bezeichnet nämlich die
bildung von über neuverschuldung
finanzierten rücklagen das ist nicht
falsch es waren ihre worte sowie die
zweckentfremdung von corona mitteln für
andere zwecke wir kommen gleich zu ihnen
noch herr doktor wird sie werden gleich
noch mal zitiert alles gut und auch die
union ist heute überzeugt davon dass ihr
eigenes völlig analoges vorgehen als
regierungspartei 2020 21 nun plötzlich
rechtswidrige finanzakrobatik sein zitat
eines csu-kollege sie will nun offenbar
im zustand des gedächtnisverlustes ihr
eigenes tun von damals das heute dass
der ampel ist nachträglich per klage in
karlsruhe prüfen lassen das könnte man
sich nicht ausdenken
die afg sieht natürlich ebenfalls und
immer noch dieses vorgehen als
rechtswidrig an immer noch deshalb weil
wir und nur wir bereits 20 21 hier im
haus entsprechende normenkontrollklagen
anträge eingebracht hatten zum nachlesen
für sie auch kollegen brinkhaus herr
dobrindt herr hase und gerne auch für
die medien drucks 19 2 29 26 von
september 2020 und 19 26 54 9 von
februar
21 kein einzige unionsabgeordneter
wollte damals diese verfassungsklagen
unterstützen und nun erklären sie
kollege haase gegenüber der fas das wort
verfassungsbruch liegt förmlich in der
luft oder eben hier jetzt gerade
verfassungswidrig sie haben sie
ausgesprochen oder was haben sie noch
gesagt nun werden corona kredite zu
klima krediten ja in der tat das war bei
ihnen das gleiche sie haben genau das
gleiche gemacht nur mit etwas kleineren
summen das ist doch reine realsatire her
die bildung von schuldenfinanzierten
rücklagen ist natürlich generell
rechtswidrig das sagen nicht nur der
gesunde ökonomische rechts verstand und
der haushalterische verstand und die afd
sondern auch der ehemalige präsident des
verfassungsgerichts kirchhoff und der
bundesrechnungshof der haushalterischen
verfassungsgrundsätze die ehrlichkeit
und klarheit verletzt sieht genau das
was irgendwie immer die fdp früher auch
so gesehen hat professor schwarz von der
uni würzburg erklärt ebenfalls das
offensichtliche zitat verfassungswidrig
eine unzulässige umgehung der
schuldenbremse und sogar der sehr
liberale starts rechte gruppe schrieb
dazu im handelsblatt verfassungsbruch
par excellence
nachlesen und dann wollen wir in der tat
den ja eben schon sehr aktiven
fdp-kollegen würde ich ganz vergessen
sie sagten ihr hat er an dieser stelle
am zweiten juli 2020 als finanzminister
scholz genau denselben rücklagen trick
rein wenden wollte zitat das protokoll
ist eindeutig dieser haushalt verstößt
gegen das grundgesetz ich verstehe nicht
warum man in der spd nur karriere machen
kann und der spd fans war vergleichbar
wenn man verfassungswidrige haushalte
vorlegt und weiter warum wird die cdu
csu fraktion hier zum helfershelfer
eines möglichen verfassungsbrecher zitat
ende heute will der
fdp-minister lindner dafür nichts mehr
hören welchen unterschied schon acht
tage an der macht machen können das ist
wirklich erstaunlich
und nochmals zu union
noch bis herbst 21 hat die union genau
dieses verfassungswidrige vorgehen als
regierungspartei mitgetragen und nun
reden sie demonstrativ
stabilitätspolitische vom
verfassungsbruch welchen unterschied
schon acht tage in der opposition
ausmachen auch das ist erstaunlich
wer vikar dobrindt ernsthaft am vorigen
dienstag der präsident der finanzpolitik
durch finanzakrobatik ersetzt der bewegt
sich schnell außerhalb des rechtsrahmens
der sollte ganz dringend in den
rückspiegel seine eigene zwei
vergangenen haushaltsjahre schauen und
verschämt schweigen
diese gelebte doppelmoral ist wirklich
kaum noch zu ertragen
nein liebe unionskollegen so leicht
kommen sie nicht aus dem verfassungs
brechenden erbe der marke heraus sie
kritisieren hier etwas was sie seit 2020
in mehreren haushalten selbst getan
haben aber die gute nachricht ist wir
sind gerne bereit in unsere
normenkontrollklagen anträge zur
verfügung zu stellen für karlsruhe
die 240 milliarden euro neuverschuldung
für 2021 dürfen nur wegen der
angeblichen pandemischen notlage
aufgenommen werden und selbstredend auch
nur für diese notlage genutzt werden das
ist das konnexitätsprinzip rechtlich
etabliert schon die groko hat es
missachtet aber die ampel macht nun gar
kein hehl mehr daraus angebliche corona
notkredite werden ganz offen als
rücklagen in den neuen klima und
transformation sfor gesteckt ein
veranlassungszusammenhang wird nicht
einmal mehr geheuchelt und der hessische
staatsgerichtshof eben schon zitiert hat
eben ein sehr ähnliches vorgang der
hessischen landesregierung für
rechtswidrig erklärt er ohne sie haben
sehr selektiv zitiert der das urteil des
hessischen gerichtshofs viele und viel
umfassender als das was sie eben gemacht
haben der finanzminister sieht seine
aufgabe heute ernsthaft als die tat
ermöglichung minister herr lindner ihre
aufgabe wäre es alles mögliche zu tun um
den steuerzahler vor weiteren super
teuren zugriffen der rot-grünen
planwirtschaft und ideologie politik zu
schützen nicht etwa diese möglich zu
machen mein letzter satz die fdp
hat beim impfzwang und bei der finanz
seriosität vor der wahl in zentralen
punkten gelogen das neue motto der fdp
scheint zu sein lieber verfassungswidrig
und wortbrüchig regieren als nicht
regieren vielen dank
wird der böhringer war das für die afg
fraktion erst der haushaltspolitische
sprecher
nächster redner für die fraktion bündnis
90/die grünen sven christian kindler
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren
bis auf ein paar rechtsradikale
verschwörungs ideologen hier im
parlament kann ja niemand bestreiten
dass wir mit weiteren das schweren
pandemischen notlage sind leider leider
ist diese partie noch lange nicht vorbei
wir müssen alles tun um die menschen in
deutschland zu schützen
als erstes natürlich durch impfen impfen
impfen das ist besonders bedauerlich
dass anscheinend der bisherige grünen
das gesundheits minister der alten
regierung nicht für genug impfstoff im
neuen jahr gesorgt hat aber wir müssen
auch mittelfristig ist das der weg aus
der krise mittelfristig ist das der weg
zur überwindung der pandemie alle die
menschen deutschland zu impfen aber
kurzfristig weißen wir auch wir brauchen
kontakt beschränkungen wir brauchen
untersagung einschränken und regional
lockdown und wir wissen auch dass wir
erhebliche wirtschaftliche folgen das
schwächt die wirtschaftleistung das ist
eine belastung für beschäftigung die
international lieferketten darf hat der
bundesfinanzminister hingewiesen sind
gestört durch die weltweite kroner
pandemie und auch wir haben zu wenig
volkswirtschaft investitionen den
letzten jahren in deutschland getätigt
durch die pandemie und ihre folgen und
deswegen hat er dort bundestag 2020 und
2021 sammelt der bundesregierung
erheblich große summen an krediten zur
bewältigung dieser pandemie
bereitgestellt und hat die
außergewöhnliche notlage nach artikel
115 ihr festgestellt und ich will ihm
mit einem missverständnis aufräumen
natürlich waren diese gelder für die
stabilisierung des gesundheitssystems
für krankenhäuser für pflegekräfte für
impfstoffe für gesundheitsämter sie
waren dafür aber natürlich nicht nur
dafür sie war natürlich auch für die
abfederung der wirtschaftlichen folgen
der pandemie für wirtschaftshilfen für
das kurzarbeitergeld
sie waren exklusiv auch für öffentliche
investitionen zur unterstützung der
wirtschaft zur stabilisierung der
volkswirtschaft dass wir immer die linie
der bundesregierung in den letzten
jahren das war die linie der breiten
mehrheit des bundestags in diesem haus
und ich finde diesen breiten konnte
sorten wie hat sich aufkündigen diesen
breiten konnte sowjetunion in der
opposition nicht auf gelegen
dann klar ist doch auch diese großen
ökonomischen einschnitte die werden
nicht einfach sofort aufhören wenn diese
pandemie überwunden ist die werden
länger auch länger andauern und jeder
vernünftige ökonom jede vernünftige
ökonomische wird ihm bestätigen dass
öffentliche investition dann nachhaltig
zum beste weg aus der krise ist und
deswegen brauchen wir es eine
grundlegende eine große
investitionsoffensive und die werden in
dieser koalition auf den weg bringen
deswegen hat die regierung jetzt einen
zweiten nachtragshaushalt zum
haushaltsgesetz 20 21 auf den weg
gebracht es wurde gesagt 60 milliarden
euro werden im energie und klimafonds
zugeführt gleichzeitig wird die höhe der
kreditermächtigung nicht erhöht die er
noch die große koalition und die union
beschlossen hat und für uns ist klar
wurde mit die wirtschaftlichen folgen
der pandemie abfedern und wir sagen wenn
wir schon investieren dann müssen wir
natürlich auch in das neue investieren
in die zukunft investieren auf den 15
grad fahrt kommen wir können nicht an
wie das alte in das fossile investieren
wir sind eine koalition dieser zukunft
verschrieben hat und deswegen sagen wir
würden sie eine politik die auch nach
vorne generationen im blick nimmt das
generationengerechte haushaltspolitik
was wir machen dass eine smarte haus als
politik
denn dazu verpflichtet auch das
völkerrechtlich verbindliche pariser
klimaschutzabkommen und dazu
verpflichtet uns auch das historische
und wegweisende urteil des
bundesverfassungsgerichts zum
klimaschutz das ist nämlich gesagt dass
der staat eine schutzpflicht hat für
nachfolgende generationen der staat hat
ein verfassungsrechtlich
schutzpflicht für unsere kinder für
unsere enkel um ihre freiheitsrechte
auch in der zukunft zu sichern deswegen
dürfen wir mit konkreten
klimaschutzmaßnahmen jetzt nicht warten
sowie ein bisschen konkret angehen das
ist die vorgabe die wir aus karlsruhe zu
erfüllen haben wir legen dafür eine
erste grundlage mit diesem
nachtragshaushalt
und deswegen ist es jetzt sinnvoll auch
finanzpolitisch zu handeln und nicht
viel später wir haben noch alle gesehen
dass in den letzten jahren in
naturkatastrophen und klimabedingten
katastrophen massiv zugenommen haben
weltweit in deutschland und europa in
deutschland haben wir von 2018 bis 2020
drei dürre sommer in folge erlebt mit
erheblichen schäden für die
landwirtschaft und unsere wälder kollege
rohde hat auf die strecke die tragödie
im aartal um nrw hingewiesen und in
rheinland pfalz und das hat auch
erhebliche belastung für die staatlichen
haushalte bund und länder rechnen mit 30
milliarden euro die diese katastrophe
alleine den staat kosten wird und das
zeigt doch wenn man klimaschutz macht
dann sagen wir auch klar dass gibt es
nicht zum nulltarif aber man kein
klimaschutz macht dann wird es am ende
richtig richtig teuer das ist die lehre
die wir hier auf sie
und ich bin ehrlich gesagt etwas
verwundert über die kritik und empörung
aus der unionsfraktion
kollege rohde hat auf die debatten zum
zweiten nachtragshaushalt 20 20 im
letzten jahr schon hingewiesen
und der hoch geschätzte kollege
ehemalige kollege eckhard rehberg damals
sprecher der unionsfraktion für
haushaltspolitik sehr guter mann während
er das mal versagt genau hat damals in
der debatte gesagt zum abschluss ist er
des zweiten nachtragshaushalts 2020 dass
er ein super ergebnis und er hat in der
ersten lesung auch hier im bundestag
ausgeführt dass wir dem
nachtragshaushalt rehm viel investiert
werden würde er sprach ich zitiere von
elektromobilität 6 milliarden
wasserstoff strategie 9 milliarden euro
energetische gebäudesanierung 2
milliarden euro mehr sagte das sind
investitionen in die zukunft um aus der
krise herauszukommen und in deutschland
zukunftsfähig zu gestalten ich finde der
kollege rehberg hatte damals vollständig
recht
er hatte recht und er bezog sich dabei
auf die investitionen aus dem energie
und klimafonds dem berechtigterweise
unter inanspruchnahme der korona
bedingten notfall kredite im zweiten
nachschuss aus 20 20 28 milliarden euro
zugeführt wurden in eine rücklage und
das war auch richtig so wie es damals
aus der opposition als grüne als
verantwortungsvolle position haben wir
samens begrüßt weil das richtig so war
und jetzt
und deswegen verstehe ich die kritik der
union nicht denn innerlich dass wir
jetzt machen dass wir damals die große
koalition 2020 gemacht haben sehr
ähnlich nur es jetzt die union in der
opposition und damals war sie in der
koalition in der regierung und im es
klar zu sagen ich finde das dass sie
einer seite so sagen andererseits ist so
sagen ich finde das nicht ehrlich dass
es keine redliche haushaltspolitik das
ist heuchelei und doppelmoral
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir
halten diesen nach sachsen fällt erst
zentralen finanzen stritt dieser neuen
koalition zeigen dass wir entschlossen
handeln dass wir diese kroner pandemie
überwinden beugen dass wir besser aus
der krise herauskommen dass wir die
großen aufgaben bei der transformation
und beim klimaschutz mit großen
investitionen angehen ich freue mich auf
die beratung dazu im weiteren verlauf im
bundestag vielen dank
sven christian kindler war das der
haushaltspolitische sprecher von bündnis
90/die grünen jahres ist die erste
lesung zu diesem nachtragsetat der die
übrig gebliebenen 60 milliarden
kreditermächtigung von der
rekordverschuldung die eigentlichen in
diesem jahr schon genehmigt war
verschieben wollen in den energie und
klimafonds
das sieht zwar nicht eine person
speziell genannt haben aber teile einer
fraktion und ich bitte darum
an eine angemessene wortwahl zu denken
das gilt für alle ich will das noch mal
sagen weil ich das am anfang meiner
antrittsrede gesagt habe dass wir hier
alle respektvoll miteinander umgehen
wollen und deshalb will ich das will ich
das nochmal einmal
für alle hier
sagen
und dann fahren wir weiter fort und das
ging damit nicht nur eines herrn
christian kindler den letzten redner
sondern an alle abgeordneten
nächste rednerin von der linken gesine
lötzsch die stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende
vielen dank frau präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren es geht um 60
milliarden euro das ist mehr als der
gesamte verteidigungsetat damit wir
einmal wissen um welche größenordnung es
geht und diese 60 milliarden will
finanzminister linda der kontrolle des
bundestages weitgehend entziehen das ist
ein angriff auf das parlament und auf
das grundgesetz ein denkbar schlechter
einstieg hatten
in der opposition hat die fdp ein
solches vorgehen als verfassungswidrig
gebrandmarkten doch einmal soll das
alles verfassungskonform sein wir sagen
ihnen ganz klar nein das ist es nicht
meine damen und herren die alte
bundesregierung war der auffassung dass
man die pandemie mit verordnungen
bekämpfen könne der bundestag wurde als
störfaktor ausgeschaltet und wir haben
gesehen wohin das führt masken dealer
schossen wie pilze aus dem boden und in
der unionsfraktion konnten wir anzeichen
von kleinkriminalität erkennen ich
erinnere nur an den csu abgeordneten
muss er hat sein mandat missbraucht um
dubiose geschäfte zu machen das ist
nicht vergessen korruption darf nicht
länger straffrei seiner damen und herren
grundrechte einzuschränken und dem
parlament die kontrollrechte zu
entziehen das ist einer demokratie
unwürdig wenn sie mehr fortschritt wagen
wollen dann geht das nur in anlehnung an
willy brandt mit mehr demokratie ohne
demokratie gibt es kein fortschritt
meine damen und herren
240 milliarden euro hat der bundestag
für die bekämpfung der pandemie als
kreditermächtigung bewilligt 60
milliarden wurden nicht ausgegeben warum
nicht fragen wir haben wir etwa genügend
luftfilter in den schulen nein haben wir
etwa ausreichend pflegekräften 1 und
jetzt kommt der höhepunkt haben wir
ausreichend impfstoffe auch das nicht
das ist doch nicht zu fassen meine damen
und herren in der vergangenen woche hat
der bundestag eine einrichtung bezogene
impfpflicht beschlossen über eine
allgemeine impfpflicht wird diskutiert
und ex minister jens spahn erklärte
immer wieder es ist ausreichend für alle
da und dann kommt der neue minister karl
lauterbach macht eigenhändig wir uns
gestern im haushaltsausschuss erklärt
hat inventur und sagt wir haben zu wenig
es ist doch unglaublich wir sind voll in
der vierten corona welle und haben zu
wenig impfstoff das ist eine große
enttäuschung für uns und für die
menschen im land rheinland
sie haben viel geld für die rettung von
dax konzern ausgegeben aber sie haben
kein geld ausgegeben für die menschen
die sich mit 450 euro jobs über wasser
halten mussten und rhone
kurzarbeitergeld von dem nicht stehen
und sie haben nichts unternommen um
ausgebildete pflegekräfte wieder in den
beruf zurück zu holen ja das kostet geld
aber das geld war auch da die alte
regierung war unfähig und unwillig
dieses geld sinnvoll auszugeben und
darum wurde sie auch zurecht abgewählt
aber
das täuschungsmanöver von herrn lindner
hat doch nur einen einzigen grund sie
brauchen dringend geld und sie wollen
nicht die steuern für die vermögenden
erhöhen sie verhalten sich nicht wie ein
bundesfinanzminister sie verhalten sich
wie ein vermögensverwalter der
superreichen und da kann ich nur sagen
die aufgabe verfehlt meine damen und
herren und ich fordere
ich fordere spd und grüne ganz deutlich
auf machen sie dieses spiel nicht mit
sie hatten in ihren wahlprogrammen
erklärt sie wollen die vermögenden
heranziehen zur finanzierung dieses
landes und davon dürfen sie sich nicht
verabschieden das ist unser appell an
sie meine damen und herren also
ziehen sie diese nachtragshaushalt
zurück und übernehmen sie unseren
sinnvollen vorschlag wir wollen eine
vermögensabgabe für das reichste 0,7
prozent ich wiederhole 0,7 prozent der
bevölkerung in diesem land da hätten wir
hohe einnahmen das wäre der richtige weg
das wäre sozial gerecht und nachhaltig
vielen dank
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die fdp-fraktion
otto fricke und afrika ist der
haushaltspolitische sprecher der
liberalen geschätzte frau präsidentin
liebe kolleginnen kollegen in zwei
minuten habe ich mir überlegt wie
erklärst du es eigentlich als mitglied
einer mitte gelb koalition der
opposition rechts links und naja da
müssen wir noch mal drüber reden also
ich will es einfach machen weil ich mich
mehr an die cdu wende weil ich da noch
hoffe dass der verstand noch zurückkehrt
nachdem man eigentlich hier nichts
anderes macht als dass man inneren
stress den man hat versucht durch einen
äußeren feind zu ersetzen das wird ihnen
auf dauer nicht gelingt versuchen wir es
so es gibt coupes das bekämpfe ich das
mache ich mit aktuellen mitteln und es
gibt long kurve da muss ich mich auch
mit beschäftigen und in der wirtschaft
liebe cdu nur wie sie es jetzt wieder
getan haben auf jährlich kite zugucken
zu gucken was mache ich heute und jetzt
ist genau so dumm wie er der ansatz zu
sagen ich bin für null neuverschuldung
das ist wie wenn sie übrigens einem
häuslebauer sagen warte mal bis zu 62
bis und genug geld gespart hast und dann
fängst du an zu bauen wir schauen auf
die nächsten jahre mit dem was wir hier
mit diesem nachtragshaushalt vorlegen
und das bedeutet ganz einfach und
verkürzt wir haben bei dem thema
investitionen ein defizit dieses werden
wir in den nächsten jahren nachholen
dafür nehmen wir einen fonds der vom
parlament begleitet wird wir werden den
haushaltsberatungen 2022 diesem fall
intensiv beraten frau kollegin löscht
geben dann auch als parlamentarier
intensiv beraten und wie ist da vorn
dann zu gestalten sowie das
verfassungsgericht ist beim thema
nachhaltigkeit gesagt hat wir sorgen an
der stelle dafür dass das was für die
wirtschaft langfristig notwendig ist und
nicht nur das was kurzfristig nötig ist
erfolgen kann zeigen dass wir diese
planung machen und geben damit die
sicherheit die sie in den letzten vier
jahren als cdu csu nicht gegeben haben
und zum schluss noch eine kleine
anmerkung
weil hier von allen seiten immer wieder
behauptet wird ja da machen sie neuen
schönen erstens keine neuen schulden das
ist der essenzielle unterschied zu dem
was sie als cdu gemacht haben in der
letzten legislatur zusätzliche schulden
aufzunehmen zweitens wir werden in der
übernächsten debatte
350 milliarden an garantien und krediten
streichen das heißt diese koalition geht
nicht nur hin sagt das was wir haben
nutzen wir wo wir es brauchen sondern
sagt auch da wo es nicht brauchen
streichen wir kreditermächtigungen das
ist moderne politik aus der mitte
herzlichen dank
sagt otto fricke für die fdp fraktion
dass er das naturgemäß anders sieht als
die union
da gibt es ja die härtesten angriffe und
die drohung damit auch nach karlsruhe zu
gehen und jetzt hören wir aus der
cdu/csu-fraktion nochmal den nächsten
redner kasten körper wird es sein es mit
dem haushaltsausschuss und
kollegen
am sonntag feiern wir den vierten advent
nächste woche ist heiligabend und die
weihnachtszeit am jahresende ist doch
für uns alle eine ganz besondere zeit
zeit der ruhe und zeit der besinnung und
sie ist auch die zeit der frohen
botschaft
in der bibel verkündete der erzengel
gabriel maria die geburt jesu und da
dachte sich jetzt offenbar die links
gelbe ampelkoalition wir haben doch es
auch eine frohe botschaft
und diese botschaft lautet geld spielt
keine rolle und der zweck heiligt die
mittel
sehr geehrter herr finanzminister
lieber herr lindner ich muss mich doch
schon sehr wundern denn ich wie auch
viele meiner kolleginnen und kollegen
auch haben noch sehr gut im ohr wie sie
und ihre kollegen von der fdp in den
vergangenen jahren die haushaltspolitik
der großen koalition gegeißelt haben als
es darum ging diesem land und seinen
menschen durch die korona pandemie zu
helfen und die korona pandemie hat uns
seit anfang vergangenen jahres fest im
griff und vor ungeahnte
herausforderungen gestellt und diese
herausforderungen waren genauso wie die
maßnahmen sie zu bekämpfen wahrhaft
historisch aber ausschließlich die
korona pandemie war die ursache für die
nachtragshaushalte in den vergangenen
beiden jahren und dieses und nichts
anderes war für uns als union die
begründung von der schwarzen null
abzuweichen und die vergangene große
koalition hat gehandelt wie sie damals
handeln musste und wir haben für 2021
eine nettokreditaufnahme von bis zu 240
milliarden euro beschlossen aber das
sehr geehrter herr finanzminister das
was sie jetzt vorhaben das ist ein
haushaltspolitischer sündenfall und das
direkt in woche zwei ihrer
regierungszeit
was haben sie vor
sie wollen 60 milliarden euro in den
energie und klimafonds schieben so weit
so gut aber wo kommt das geld her im
vergangenen jahr 2020 lag der rahmen der
korona bedingten nettokreditaufnahme bei
bis zu 217 milliarden euro
130 milliarden wurden im vergangenen
jahr zur bekämpfung der korona pandemie
tatsächlich in anspruch genommen
immerhin 87 milliarden wurden nicht in
anspruch genommen in diesem jahr haben
wir einen netten kreditaufnahme von bis
zu 240 milliarden euro natürlich eine
nettokreditaufnahme von historischem
ausmaß bisher wurden in diesem jahr
allerdings davon 180 milliarden in
anspruch genommen und die wolken
zielgerichtet in diesem jahr zur
pandemie bekämpfung eingesetzt ganz so
wie es artikel 115 grundgesetz mit der
ausnahme von der schuldenregel
vorschreibt aber da bleibt doch noch 60
milliarden offen diese werden aktuell
nicht für corona benötigt eine seriöse
regierung würde jetzt diese 60
milliarden nicht in anspruch nehmen 60
milliarden die von unseren kindern und
enkeln in der zukunft nicht
zurückgezahlt werden müssten das aber
sehr geehrter herr finanzminister ficht
sie offenbar nicht an sie wollen diese
60 milliarden schulden trotzdem
aufnehmen schlimmer noch sie wollen
diese zweckgebundenen mittel umwidmen
klimaschutz ist ihre begründung klingt
ja total gut aber am ende des tages
heiligt der zweck eben doch nicht die
mittel sie wollen
sie wollen letztlich geld für die
zukunft bonbon sie wollen dafür eine
haushalts regler rücklage über kredite
finanzieren und verletzten damit erstens
das haushalts gebot der ehrlichkeit weil
sie erst frühestens ab 2023 an diese
mittel tragen wollen und mit der
umwidmung zum klimaschutz verletzten sie
zweitens zu dem artikel 115 grundgesetz
da die ausnahme von der schuldenregel
ausschließlich mit der pandemie
begründet wurde und
und diese begründung diese begründung
lassen sie jetzt fallen und versuchen
den klimawandel generell als
außergewöhnliche notsituation zu
definieren damit versetzen sie sehr
geehrter herr finanzminister der sich
doch immer eigentlich fan der
schuldenbremse waren der schuldenbremse
den todesstoß und drittens sie
verletzten mit ihrem tun auch das
wirtschaftlichkeitsgebot für geld das
nicht gebraucht wird dürfen keine
kredite in anspruch genommen werden
gegen all diese regeln verstoßen sie ihn
dann fragt man sich warum tun sie das
ganz einfach sie haben zu vielen zu
vieles versprochen und das fällt ihnen
jetzt auf die füße deshalb kommen sie
jetzt mit einem rechtlich höchst
zweifelhaften konstrukt eines kann ich
ihnen sagen die union wird ihnen diesen
nachtragshaushalt zu nicht durchgehen
lassen wir werden uns in karlsruhe
wieder sehen sehr geehrter herr lindner
dass das was sie hier abliefern das ist
kein signal ihrer handlungsfähigkeit und
auch kein ausdruck von gestaltungswillen
das ist ein haushaltspolitisches
armutszeugnis ein armutszeugnis dass man
von einem aufrechten liberalen so nicht
erwartet hätte vielen dank
coskun körper für die cdu/csu-fraktion
der sich ebenfalls am
bundesfinanzminister abgearbeitet hat
vor allem von den liberalen hätte man
das so nicht erwartet der
bundesfinanzminister hat übrigens ja zum
auftakt dieser debatte aber auch gerade
in richtung der cdu csu fraktion gesagt
dass es die zusage gibt dass die mittel
des fonds zielgerichtet eingesetzt
werden also nicht für irgendwas was die
ampel planen sondern eben für
investitionen in klimaschutz
ich habe hier schon ein bisschen
eigentlich wenn ich so an die debatten
der letzten jahre denke und denke mir so
als sozialdemokratinnen wir sind
wahrscheinlich diejenigen die noch am
ehesten nicht mit ihren zitaten aus der
debatte des nachtragshaushaltes 2020
konfrontiert werden können denn wir
fanden es damals richtig dass wir
gemeinsam in der großen koalition auf
vorschlag von unserem finanzminister
olaf scholz gemacht haben indem wir den
28 milliarden euro mit dem zweiten
nachtragshaushalt für
zukunftsinvestitionen
in den ekd verbracht haben übrigens mit
der zustimmung und dem beifall der cdu
csu fraktion und den protest der fdp ja
das ist richtig aber heute ist das
instrument und zwar eigentlich exakt das
gleiche instrument was wir damals
angewandt haben natürlich immer noch
richtig und es ist auch
verfassungskonform
und
darum möchte ich kurz zitieren ich würde
gerne mehr zitieren dass selbst meine
redezeit nicht zu aber es lohnt sich für
sie alle das nachzulesen der
wissenschaftliche dienst des bundestags
hat sich nämlich damals mit diesem
haushalt ausführlich beschäftigt und ich
möchte nur aus der zusammenfassung der
vielen seiten folgendes vorlesen mit der
letzten zielsetzung
längerfristig verbundene nachhaltige
wirtschafts effekte tragen dazu bei
zurück im interesse zukünftiger
generationen
aktiv zu werden und vor diesem
hintergrund und in anbetracht der
unsicherheiten hinsichtlich der krisen
dauer erscheint die maßnahmen geeignet
und darum erforderlich lesen sie das
bitte gerne alles nochmal ausführlich
nach weil dazu werden wir noch
gelegenheit haben und darum möchte ich
sagen es ist hier schon gesprochen
worden von den brücken die in die
zukunft führen sollen dass es darum
wichtig ist auch die zielsetzung von
maßnahmen nachzujustieren die nacht zu
schärfen und nichts anderes tun wir und
wer schon vor allem das dass wir nämlich
die milliarden die wir für investitionen
zu über der wind zur überwindung der
krise bereitgestellt haben auch wirklich
für die zukunft weitere einsätze
behalten und das liebe kolleginnen und
liebe kollegen von der union ist doch
etwas was uns auch in der vergangenheit
gemeinsam getragen hat und es sei mir
der hinweis gestattet wir haben es nicht
nur hier im deutschen bundestag getan
mit dem zweiten nachtragshaushalt 2020
wir haben es auch auf europäischer ebene
getan und wir haben es übrigens auch
schon in der großen koalition in der
finanz und wirtschaftskrise getan das
probate mittel und unser gemeinsamer
geist her davon getragen dass man in die
krise nicht hinein sparen darf sondern
dass man sie überwinden muss im sinne
der menschen im sinne der menschen die
beschäftigt sind die bleiben müssen
im sinne der unternehmen die die
prosperität in unserem land erzeugen im
sinne auch unsere europäischen nachbarn
verstehe ich von europa wie schon
genannt weil nur wenn es unseren
europäischen nachbarn gut geht können
sie bei uns einkaufen und wir sind eine
exportnation und wir leben davon dass es
uns ein in europa gut geht und darum
haben wir in der letzten großen
koalition gemeinsam mit angela merkel
gemeinsam mit ursula von der leyen 750
milliarden euro verfügbar gemacht in
europa ein eigenmittel beschluss hier im
deutschen bundestag herbeigeführt warum
denn um die krise in ganz europa zu
bekämpfen und dazu gehört eben nicht nur
dass man die krankenhäuser stabilisiert
dass man impfstoffe einkauft masken und
so weiter mehr dazu gehört auch dass man
die menschen in beschäftigung hält das
man massenarbeitslosigkeit vermeidet
dass man dafür sorgt dass es den
familien dass es den kindern gut geht
das in die schulen in die kitas
investiert werden kann und all das
ermöglichen wir in deutschland und in
europa und liebe kollegen von der cdu
csu das war letztes jahr richtig und es
bleibt auch in diesem jahr richtig und
weil das so ist und
weil ich
weil ich ganz viele von ihnen aus der
zusammenarbeit gut kenne ihn sehr
schätze würde ich mir wünschen dass wir
ihre neue oppositionsrolle wirklich an
der stelle einsetzen wo es möglich
erforderlich ist wir leben jetzt vom
streit im deutschen bundestag aber das
was sie hier machen es ist im höchsten
maße inkonsequent und damit
unglaubwürdig und es schadet uns ansehen
als politik insgesamt und darum bitte
ich sie überdenken sie das doch nochmal
der breite konsens den wir hier diesem
haus entwickelt haben zur überwindung
der krise im deutschen bundestag und in
europa insgesamt der ist richtig der
bleibt richtig und er ist die grundlage
dafür dass die menschen uns vertrauen
und dass sie der demokratie vertrauen
dass gemeinsam zu stärken darum geht es
auch und weil das so ist danke ich nicht
für den guten entwurf empfehle ihn zur
zustimmung im januar so lange können wir
debattieren er machte noch eine anhörung
hat der haushaltsausschuss gestern
beschlossen wir nehmen ihre bedenken
ernst aber bitte erinnern sie sich an
das was sie noch im letzten jahr so
richtig gehalten haben es war richtig
vielen dank
bevor ich den nächsten redner aufrufe
hat der abgeordnete helge braun das wort
zu einer kurzintervention
gebrauchen ist der neue vorsitzende des
finanziell des haushaltsausschuss ist
natürlich
sie haben gesagt wir werden inkonsequent
und unglaubwürdig in unserer position
aber deshalb möchte ich sie fragen ob
sie nicht folgendes auch einmal
überdenken bein wenn das was hier
geschieht 60 milliarden euro werden in
die zukunft verschoben an schulden und
werden für wie sie gesagt haben brücken
in die zukunft verwendet und damit wenn
wir das in zukunft zum standard unserer
haushaltspolitik machen haben wir der
höhe nach keine begrenzung der ausgaben
finanzierten schulden in den nächsten
jahren und das ist das exakte gegenteil
von dem was die schuldenbremse vorsieht
und deshalb will ich auch weil der
bundesfinanzminister so auf die
freundschaftliche zusammenarbeit im
haushaltsausschuss hingewiesen hat auf
die freue ich mich auch aber ich bitte
auch um 1 mich nicht dafür was sie hier
machen und in die mithaftung zu nehmen
weil erstens das was ich im januar
gefordert habe war das was die fdp
massiv bekämpft hat also dass sie noch
180 grad wende machen das ist schon mal
sehr sehr eindeutig das zweite das was
ich damals gesagt habe war sehr klar wir
brauchen wir waren damals in einer
finanziell schwierigen lage in corona
und wenn wir dauerhaft die
schuldenbremse nicht einhalten müssen
brauchen wir dafür eine gesetzliche
grundlage
im juni hat der stabilitätsrat aber sehr
deutlich gesagt wir können im jahr 2023
die schuldenbremse wieder einhalten
damit ist das obsolet und deshalb will
ich hier nur noch mal sagen anders als
sie sich das wünschen liebe frau hagen
wir werden und auch ich persönlich
werdet dem vorgehen was sie haben nicht
die hand reichen das ist die axt an der
schuldenbremse
[Musik]
frau h geworden möchten sie antworten
bitte
lieber kollege braun dieser
nachtragshaushalt ist nicht die axt an
der schuldenbremse und ich habe im
übrigen im einem redebeitrag auch gar
nicht auf sie abgezielt und ihre
äußerung dass man andere kollegen hier
in der debatte aber fakt ist doch dass
sie im letzten jahr mit ihren
bemerkungen nicht etwa von uns oder
anderen sondern von der eigenen parteien
eigenen fraktionen gestoppt worden sind
die ein lautes nachdenken über die
schuldengrenze die ich haben wollte
in unserem koalitionsvertrag haben wir
uns alle gemeinsam darauf verpflichtet
die schuldenbremse einzuhalten und das
ist auch gut so weil wir doch gerade
erleben dass die schuldenbremse so wie
sie im grundgesetz steht eben auch in
einer krise die finanziellen spielräume
ermöglicht die erforderlich sind um
diese krise zu bekämpfen wir mit der
zustimmung des deutschen bundestages
haben wir doch diese krise von
nationaler tragweite
ausgerufen und damit spielräume im
haushalt die sinnvoll sind und darum
musste darum muss die schuldenbremse
auch nicht im grundgesetz verändert
werden wir wollen sie einhalten weil wir
davon ausgehen dass wir die konsequenzen
aus der pandemie ab 20 23 soweit im
griff haben dass man das bewältigen kann
ohne in die krise rein zu sparen das
glauben wir und dafür ist das was wir
jetzt machen ein probates mittel das sie
in der großen koalition auch schon
erprobt haben indem wir 28 milliarden
euro in den kampf geschickt haben und
das ist richtig ich habe auch den
wissenschaftlichen dienst verwiesen weil
es zulässig ist nicht nur medizinische
maßnahmen zu ergreifen mit diesen
mitteln sondern sehr wohl auch in die
stabilität der gesellschaft und vor
allem der wirtschaft zu investieren und
das war damals wichtig das kleid richtig
darum und darum das habe ich gemeint ich
habe die zusammenarbeit mit ihnen immer
geschätzt mit ihm und darum würde ich
auch gerne weiter auf diese art und
weise mit ihnen zusammenarbeiten
auch die grünen und der sozialdemokraten
haben damals in der griechenland-krise
ich möchte daran erinnern als opposition
sind wir nicht der versuchung erlegen
einfach dagegen zu sein sondern wir
haben sie unterstützt obwohl wir viele
maßnahmen im detail nicht richtig fanden
damals und daran appelliere ich nur
daran weil das was damals richtig war
dem ich vor einem jahr das bleibt jetzt
auch richtig und es ist die grundlage
für diesen nachtragshaushalt vielen dank
ob diese appelle von bettina hagedorn
hier bei der union ankommen dass im
nächsten jahr sehen abgestimmt wird
heute über diesen nachtragshaushalt noch
nicht der ja keine neuen schulden
aufnimmt sondern alte verschiebt
sozusagen sondern erst im januar aber
wichtig war in diesem jahr noch die
zuleitung zu machen deswegen hat die
ampel hier diesen gesetzentwurf
vorgelegt sebastian schäfer hören wir
jetzt für die grünen
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte damen und
herren als bund nehmen wir in diesem
jahr kredite in höhe von bis zu 240
milliarden euro auf es ist ungefähr die
hälfte der wirtschaftsleistung von baden
württemberg das ist eine gewaltige summe
der geltende bundeshaushalt wurde noch
von der großen koalition beschlossen und
nicht von unserer fortschritts koalition
und dennoch kann ich sagen der beschluss
dieser rekord verschuldung ist auch in
der großen koalition nicht
leichtfertiger folgt
frau bundeskanzlerin dr merkel hat im
zusammenhang mit der korona pandemie von
der größten krise in unserem land seit
dem zweiten weltkrieg gesprochen und
leider müssen wir in diesen tagen
feststellen dass die krise nicht nur
nach wie vor anhält sondern sich noch
einmal verschärft hat mit extremen
belastungen unserer pfleger und ärzte in
den kliniken und einer furchtbaren zahl
von menschen jeden tag an und mit corona
versterben
auf unsere wirtschaft ist weiterhin
schwer von der krise betroffen wir alle
hier
außer die krise lieben hätten uns eine v
förmige erholung der wirtschaft
gewünscht aber das trifft leider nicht
so ein gerade haben das münchner ifo
institut und das institut für
wirtschaftsforschung in halle ihre
wachstumsprognosen für 2022 teils
deutlich nach unten korrigiert es
besteht also weiterhin die notwendigkeit
die wirtschaftliche erholung mit
staatlichen investitionen zu
stabilisieren
wenn unser land ökonomisch stabil ist
hagedorn hat es gesagt profitieren davon
auf unsere europäischen nachbarn mit
denen wir wirtschaftlich so eng
verflochten sind wir tragen auch dafür
verantwortung und jenseits aller
notwendigen solidarität wir haben auch
was davon
mit dem klima und transformations- vor
und mit diesem nachtragshaushalt eben
wie die richtige antwort auf die
wirtschaftliche herausforderung der
pandemie damit können die investitionen
umgesetzt werden und private
investitionen weiter an gereizt werden
die ausgeblieben sind in der panini wir
müssen dem geld eine neue richtung geben
die transformation unserer gesamten
wirtschaft zur klimaneutralität die
dekarbonisierung insbesondere der
industrie das ist eine gigantische
herausforderung
ich vertrete den wahlkreis esslingen im
deutschen bundestag wir haben einen
hohen anteil an industrielle
wertschöpfung mit vielen gut bezahlten
arbeitsplätzen das ist bei vielen von
ihnen hier ähnlich nicht nur in baden
württemberg und wir brauchen diese gut
bezahlten arbeitsplätze diese
industrielle wertschöpfung die wir in
deutschland haben auch in zukunft dafür
nehmen wir jetzt geld in die hand um die
korona pandemie wirtschaftlich schnell
zu überwinden und diese notwendige
transformation zu einem erfolg zu machen
für unser land
wir werden aber nicht nur den
investitionsrückstand in der
ampelkoalition an wir schaffen mit einem
modernen einwanderungsgesetz auch die
grundlage mit der zunehmenden
schwierigeren demografischen entwicklung
in unserem land umzugehen mit dem
spurwechsel nutzen wir die potenziale
jetzt schon in unserem land vorhanden
sind statt diese weiter brach liegen zu
lassen
wir haben viel nachzuholen viel zu viel
ist liegen geblieben in diesen letzten
jahren trotz guter steuereinnahmen und
immer niedrigere zinsbelastungen für die
öffentlichen haushalte
dafür schaffen wir jetzt die grundlage
mit dem vorliegenden nachtragshaushalt
und dann im neuen jahr mit dem regulären
bundeshaushalt 2022 wir gehen sorgsam
mit den öffentlichen mitteln um in
dieser koalition auch das verbindet uns
herzlichen dank
[Applaus]
vielen dank das war übrigens zeitlich
eine punktlandung herzlichen glück von
staat zu
mixen und das bei der ersten rede da
gibt es doch noch mal ein besonderes lob
von der präsidentin florian rösner für
die cdu csu fraktion
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der neue fdp
finanzminister heute
erstaunlich zurückhaltend in seiner rede
zum nachtragshaushalt offensichtlich
sind sie selbst nicht die haut überzeugt
für den ersten meisterstück ist offenbar
ein großer fehler des schriftstellers
mark twain nach dem motto von jetzt an
werde ich nur so viel ausgeben wie ich
einnehme selbst wenn ich mir dafür geld
borgen anders kann ich mir nämlich nicht
erklären wie das versprechen der soliden
finanzen des ministers keine woche nach
amtsantritt gehalten hat nochmals 60
milliarden euro für die finanzierung
nebulöser projekte abzuzweigen ist
einfach inakzeptabel und
verfassungsrechtlich mehr als bedenklich
in diesem in diesem jahr wurde wegen der
panini eine gigantische 240 milliarden
euro kreditlinie aufgenommen eine
unvorstellbare summe hiervon wurden gott
sei dank gott sei dank rund 60
milliarden euro nicht benötigt was
grundsätzlich positiv ist also statt 240
milliarden euro zusatz schulden nur in
anführungszeichen
180 milliarden euro zusätzliche
belastungen für die deutsche bevölkerung
so würde man als normalsterblicher
denken aber nein nicht so in der
finanzierungs logik der ampelkoalition
die neue bundesregierung als spd grüne
und fdp plant nun stattdessen diese
mittel dem sogenannten energie und
klimafonds gutzuschreiben man kann sich
durchaus fragen was der frisch gewählte
finanzminister dazu noch vor ein paar
wochen gesagt hätte wäre jetzt nicht
selbst an der regierung beteiligt auch
ganz nach dem neuen
fdp-fraktionschef tür karriere kann man
nur machen wenn man verfassungswidrige
haushalte vorliegt damals galt es noch
für die spd jetzt gilt es für die fdp
ist das was dir machen der rentner in
der tat ihr verständnis vom richtig
regierende fdp für uns als cdu csu
fraktion hat dies jedenfalls nichts mit
seriösen wirtschaften zu tun
auch die begründung der links gelben
koalition für diesen zweiten
nachtragshaushalt ist mehr als
fragwürdig denn wenn die mittel nun für
klima investitionen in den kommenden
jahren genutzt werden fehlt der bezug
zur pandemie notlage mit der aussetzung
der schuldenbremse gemäß artikel 115
ursprünglich begründet war im falle von
naturkatastrophen steht da und
außergewöhnlichen notsituationen die
sich der kontrolle des staates entziehen
und die staatliche finanzlage erheblich
beeinträchtigen können diese
kreditobergrenze aufgrund des
beschlusses der mehrheit der mitglieder
des bundestages überschritten werden
klarer fall nun waren aber die mittel
ausreichend für dieses jahr ist besteht
überhaupt kein grund nun zusätzliche
geldmittel in einem fonds zu parken ist
sei denn man möchte diese gelder
überhaupt nicht für katastrophen
bedingte ausgaben verwenden und da bin
ich schon froh dass auch mittlerweile
der bundesminister habe ich für den ja
dieses große geschenk mittlerweile da
ist die erste halbe stunde hatte nicht
der debatte beigewohnt ich denke liebe
ampel diese buchungstricks können und
dürfen wir ihnen als cdu/csu nicht
durchgehen lassen
würde man nun der argumentation der
ampelkoalition folgen hätten wir
aufgrund des klimawandels und der
notwendigen transformation der
wirtschaft eine permanent
außergewöhnliche notsituation die eine
über die 0 35 prozent regel
hinausgehende neuverschuldung im
bundeshaushalt ermöglichen würde dies
hätte eine dauerhafte aussetzung der
schuldenbremse zur folge ja sogar die
komplette auflösung dieser
schuldengrenze ein schelm wer böses
dabei denkt liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
in der klimapolitik dringend rodeln geht
doch auch völlig zurecht die belange der
nächsten generation zu berücksichtigen
in der haushaltspolitik scheint der
neuen bundesregierung die
generationengerechtigkeit jedoch absolut
egal zu sein wie passt das zusammen die
faz kommentierte aus meiner sicht zu
treffen die nachtragshaushalt am letzten
freitag gefolgt in normalen jahren
erlaubte schuldenregel eine
neuverschuldung von etwa 12 milliarden
euro das zeigt es geht hier jetzt nicht
nur um einen schluck aus der pulle
sondern um das laufen gleich mehrere
kanister zitat ende ist
es ist und bleibt falsch weshalb wir als
union diesen völlig unnötigen
nachtragshaushalt ablehnen und auch eine
gerichtliche überprüfung durchführen
alles andere wäre auch völlig
unverantwortlich
der der hessische staatsgerichtshof
heute schon mehrfach zitiert hat in
einem ähnlichen fall ja dazu bereits
entschieden das kreditfinanzierte
maßnahmen zur krisenbewältigung nicht
nur geeignet erforderlich und angemessen
sondern auch final auf die beseitigung
der notsituation gerichtet sein müssen
verheerend es aus meiner sicht auch die
signalwirkung an unsere europäische
familie wie sollen wir unsere euro
partner von einer soliden
haushaltsführung überzeugen um den euro
stabil zu halten falls mir selbst die
größten sünder sind als stärkste
volkswirtschaft europas haben wir nicht
nur das meiste risiko zu tragen sondern
auch unmissverständliche vorbildfunktion
zu erfüllen meine lieben kolleginnen und
kollegen
das alles hier ist nicht gegeben und
weit entfernt von dem was man als
nachhaltige haushaltspolitik bezeichnen
kann zumal ab dem jahr 2026 die panini
schulden getilgt werden und ein deutlich
geringerer handlungsspielraum für
zukünftige investitionen besteht deshalb
abschließend auf schuldenbergen kann man
keine zukunft bauen die sie bilden eben
kein dauerhaft festes fundament
herzliches vergelt's gott fürs zuhören
florian oßner war das für die cdu csu
fraktion jetzt wenn wir noch einen
redner in dieser debatte zum zweiten
nachtragshaushalt der kommt von den
sozialdemokraten andreas schwarz sehr
verehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine sehr
verehrten damen und herren an dem
fernsehbildschirm max frisch hat mal
gesagt es ist ein produktiver zustand
man muss ihr nur den beigeschmack der
katastrophe nehmen
ja wir sind in einem starken land mit
einem starken start wir haben kreative
unternehmen und wir haben fleißige
menschen die hier arbeiten ja und dieses
land war wahrlich gefordert in den
letzten zwei jahren und wir waren noch
produktiv und ich werde ihnen auch sagen
warum fangen wir bei den menschen an die
mussten ihr leben ändern und sie haben
das angenommen von masten pflicht
abstands pflichten und und und wir haben
in einer rekordzeit einen impfstoff
entwickelt das zeigt die klugen köpfe in
unserem land die am test und impfzentren
in betrieb genommen unser kranken system
wurde hoch gefahren um mit den problemen
fertig zu werden es wurden finanzielle
hilfen schnell organisiert um
arbeitsmarkt und wirtschaft zu
stabilisieren
ja und zwischendurch war noch ein paar
kleine und große wahlen in dem land das
heißt es muss die neue regierung finden
und bilden dass es auch schnell passiert
sie kam auch zügig in den arbeitsmodus
und schlägt auch hier ganz schnell
gesetze vor wir haben einen gestaltungs
auf einen fortschritt fortschritts
willen wir haben am ende auch sehr viel
verantwortung zu tragen meine damen und
herren trotz der pandemie die wir uns
sicherlich viel abverlangt hat wird mit
sicherheit auch feststehen die wird auch
noch ein bisschen dauern und wir müssen
gesundheit gesellschaft wirtschaft
weiter stabilisieren während karl
lauterbach gerade ausreichend impfstoff
für die menschen im land organisiert
kümmert sich unser finanzminister um die
notwendige finanzielle booster impfung
für unsere wirtschaft liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen gerade weil die situation
so ist wie sie ist
müssen wir die wirtschaftlichen
auswirkungen weiterhin genau im auge
behalten und alles dafür tun die
deutsche volkswirtschaft wieder auf
einen langfristigen nachhaltigen
wachstumspfad zu führen das schafft
generationengerechtigkeit weil wir in
die zukunft investieren und die zukunft
im blick haben dafür benötigen wir hier
mit dem vorgelegten zweiten
nachtragshaushalt diese 60 milliarden
euro die wir in den energie und dann
stabilisierungsfonds oder
transformations- vorüber führen werden
wir nutzen einfach nicht genutzte
kredite weil wir ihnen dem land aufgrund
der pandemie gerade nicht ausgeben
konnten und liebe ehemaligen
koalitionspartner der union das haben
wir im letzten jahr ja auch schon
erfolgreich mit 26 milliarden euro getan
und ich bin mir sicher dass das auch mit
unserer verfassung konform geht warum
diesen optimismus liebe mitbürgerinnen
und mitbürger ziel ist es wir wollen
nachhaltig aus der krise kommen um
fortschritt für dieses land zu
organisieren man spart nicht in die
krise bald das kostet uns und unsere
nachhaltige nationen zukunft es geht um
digitalisierung transformation und
klimaschutz und über das entscheiden wir
hier in diesem parlament ja gemeinsam
wie geld wann wo ausgegeben wird also
keine angst und gerade
klimaschutzmaßnahmen sind von besonderer
bedeutung nicht erinnere an die
rechtsprechung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts dass uns
einiges an hausaufgaben
aufgegeben hat um unser land
zukunftsfähig zu machen arbeitsplätze zu
sichern und die menschen in diese neue
zeit zu begleiten sie merken liebe
kolleginnen kollegen es geht um
investitionen die über das normale maß
eines bundeshaushalts hinaus geben neben
der pandemie geht es um transformation
und wachstum in diesem land und dies
gleichzeitig und erschwerten
konjunkturellen bedingungen wir werden
die öffentlichen investitionen die
investitionen verstärken und durch eine
weitere steigerung auch private
investitionen nachhaltig anstoßen das
schafft anreize und das schafft
planungssicherheit für die menschen in
diesem land auch für die unternehmen in
diesem land dies ist eine wichtige
signalwirkung uns klare impulse die
notwendig sind für unsere wirtschaft
letztendlich ist es nicht nur eine
deutliche weiterführung unserer
hilfsmaßnahmen zur überwindung der
pandemie sondern es ist auch ein
sichtbarer einstieg zur nachhaltigen
finanzierung zur überwindung der
klimakrise das sichert nicht nur
vorhandene arbeitsplätze sondern auch
für weitere
beschäftigungsmöglichkeiten und vor
allen dingen für starke impulse für
unsere wirtschaft ich nenne das
krisenbewältigung erster klasse die wir
vornehmen meine damen und herren sie
sehen wir leisten uns mit unserer
finanzpolitik beide in einen starken und
deutlichen beitrag damit der soziale und
wirtschaftliche frieden in diesem land
und auch der erfolg in diesem land
gesichert wird zum abschluss meine damen
und herren mit diesem nachtrag zum
bundeshaushalt setzen wir klare impulse
für das land mir bleibt insofern nur
kurz zum beginn meiner rede zurück zu
kommen und meine tiefste überzeugung
kundzutun krise ist durchaus ein
produktiver zustand und ich ergänzen mit
den worten helmut schmidt in der krise
bewahrt sich der wahre charakter und
dieses land hat charakter in diesem
sinne danke und ich freue mich auf die
weiteren beratungen
sagt andreas schwarz und diese weiteren
beratungen zum gesetzentwurf zum zweiten
nachtragshaushalt wird es geben unter
anderem im haushaltsausschuss denn der
gesetzentwurf wird an diesem letzten
sitzungstag des bundestages in dieser in
diesem jahr dann dort fortgesetzt werden
die beratungen und dann im nächsten jahr
wird das ganze abgestimmt die zuführung
noch in diesem jahr zu machen diese 60
milliarden sozusagen muss sich schon auf
den weg zu bringen damit diese
kreditermächtigung nicht verfallen das
gelte war schon mal genehmigung vom
bundestag nämlich dem vorherigen
finanzminister diese 60 milliarden
kreditermächtigung sind übriggeblieben
und ja was man jetzt damit macht das ist
hier auf sehr unterschiedliche resonanz
gestoßen das hatte sich im vorfeld ja
auch schon angedeutet also die
ampelkoalition ehre und die opposition
kommen punkt nicht zusammen ein booster
für die volkswirtschaft sagt
beispielsweise der bundesfinanzminister
christian lindner dazu das geld in den
energie und klimafonds zu überführen und
dann für investitionen zwecke und zu
nutzen und die opposition die
unionsfraktion ganz vorneweg zweifelt an
dass das verfassungsgemäß ist und wirft
ihr haushaltstricks dem
bundesfinanzminister und der ampel
koalition vor und dann wollen wir mal
sehen wie das nächstes jahr weitergeht
ob die union dann wie angekündigt
wirklich nach karls gerät und vom
bundesverfassungsgericht dagegen klagen